today we're welcoming back arthur brooks
it's been uh it's been decades since
arthur's been on he's a harvard
professor phd social scientist
best-selling author writes at the
atlantic and the latest book is from
strength to strength finding success
happiness and deep purpose in the second
half of life which you'll i s at some
point in the next decade you will enter
i guess
well it yeah if i'm not it's like enough
of life now is i'm going to be living at
least 116 years and that i don't know i
got the data seems unlikely well you
know aspirationally in the jewish faith
we say 120 you know so so 60 yeah yeah i
mean you live to 120. and by the the
title of the book by the way is mikhail
with from the 84th psalm may you go from
strength to strength that's where the
title of the book comes from that's uh
well there's some there's really
something for everyone i mean let's zoom
out a little bit the the mindfulness
space
the happiness hacking space you know
it's become so riddled with
newsletters
self-help books
hacks the top three the best ten you
know all these sort of different things
and i get that they're all kind of
pointing to what it seems to me is that
a lot of people are experiencing some
kind of fundamental
absence of something and
there's different ways that we can deal
with that either by sort of workshopping
and hacking for some it's finding
religion or higher purpose or faith or
whatever the case may be what's your
overall assessment of how this space has
become so huge in the last 10 years
well to begin with it's the reason that
we haven't mastered it i mean look we
all want to be happy and we're not so
obviously there's something wrong here
and part of the reason is because mother
nature is just lying to us all all the
time
the biggest mistake that we all make is
thinking that if we actually get what we
want we'll be happy that's completely
incorrect
and it's based on the false assumption
that mother nature cares if you're happy
see mother nature is is
encouraging you to accumulate money and
power and pleasure and fame and
therefore and since you want to be happy
and you want those things you make the
connection of thinking if i get those
things i'm going to be happy well that's
mother nature's joke
she basically wants you to pass on your
jeans dave she wants you to have 75
children by getting as rich and famous
as possible she does not care she
doesn't care at all whether you're happy
and that's the big mistake that we make
the truth is that being happy requires
that we do things that are contrary to
our basic nature a lot and most people
don't know how to do that most people
don't want to do that and that's the
reason that we still haven't mastered
this art does this uh relate in some way
to the concept of the hedonic treadmill
where you identify what you think is
sort of like an end point at which you
will achieve some level of happiness or
satisfaction then you get there and it
turns out uh it doesn't really look the
same now that i'm here and you kind of
move goal posts is that related to the
same desire that that maybe is
not not what we think it is
very much so happiness basically comes
from three things
there's sort of three macronutrients in
happiness kind of like food is protein
carbohydrates and fat happiness is
enjoyment meaning and satisfaction those
are the three parts of happiness you
have to have all three and all three are
hard all three actually require work and
they require habits not hacks they
require that you take these things
seriously they require knowledge and and
and so the last of those satisfaction is
the one that you're talking about
satisfaction is the joy that you got
from a job well done or getting a reward
that you really wanted
mother nature tells you that if you get
that thing that the the joy that you get
is gonna last forever so mick jagger
sings i can't get no satisfaction but i
try and i try and i try now
the truth is that you can get
satisfaction the problem is that you
can't keep satisfaction that's what you
call the hedonic treadmill the science
behind that is a thing called
homeostasis that's where the brain
always goes back to its baseline so if
you in your body does too by the way if
your pulse goes up after being on the
treadmill and then after you get off it
goes back down to your pulse your
regular pulse rate that's so you don't
die that's homeostasis but emotionally
our homeostasis means we can't stay out
of our groove by being happier than
normal because we won't be ready for the
next set of circumstances and the
pleistocene we'd be somebody's lunch
fast if we weren't ready to react
emotionally to the next set of
circumstances that's homeostasis but we
don't know it because mother nature is
lying to us and saying that new car
smells going to last forever that the
sunshine in california is going to make
you happy forever that that new romance
is going to give you a thrill forever
that my students at the harvard business
school when they get that great job it's
going to be awesome forever because they
got all this money no you'll like it
when you hear about the raise but you
won't even care about it when it hurts
it hits your check because of the
helonic treadmill so you need to hack
that you need new habits to get beyond
that and that's what i write about my in
the work that i do look the
self-improvement space is
not very scientific if you really want
to be happier you got to do habits you
got to do the work and you have to share
it with other people you need to become
a real student of this stuff and then
you truly can be happier you mentioned
there's so many of these different
instances that can be kind of delved
into more and researched more one about
the idea of if i move to a place with
better weather uh i'll just i'll i'll be
happier year round because when i'm
there for a little bit it seems so great
um there's a bunch of interesting work
on that and one study i read says that
it is true for like a couple years and
then it just kind of becomes the status
quo and then it almost starts to become
interesting to think about places that
have seasons that have winter and all of
a sudden that kind of becomes more
appealing there's also the counter
factual of of the in terms of
self-reported happiness
places with pretty crummy weather and
cold temperatures are regularly at the
top of self-reported happiness as well
which should make us it should make us
say what i guess
yeah i mean nobody says i want to move
to denmark for the weather right but
denmark comes out on top of these
happiness scales and comparisons of
people in different countries now those
actual comparisons are nonsense because
you can't really compare people in
different countries who have different
cultures but you can compare people
within regions and indeed you find that
in a lot of places like the upper
midwest people actually are they tend to
be just as happy or happier than people
in california and the main reason is
because weather isn't what brings you
happiness what brings you happiness is
your faith or life philosophy your
transcendent self sense of what what the
what the world is all about whether it's
religious or not your family life your
friendships and work that serves other
people in other words it's all about
love and in a lot of places in the upper
midwest they have better communities and
healthier families than they have in
places in southern california the key
thing to keep in mind is your brain says
to get that unless you have a seasonal
affective disorder or something i'm
talking about people who don't and it's
only about seven or eight percent of
people have that but if you don't have
that your brain's saying you'll be
happier in the sunshine and you will
enjoy it of course i mean i've lived in
southern california periodically
throughout my life
but the real happiness bump that comes
from happiness will wear off in six
months and the taxes are forever so
choose wisely well so that that's where
your uh former professional conservative
uh career come comes out for sure uh
which by the way i wanna i wanna link
back to all of all of this in a bit so
what are you talked about there there
are things that you can do to kind of
hack these tendencies for lack of a
better term so what are they
well so the key thing is it's again it's
not hacks it's habits that's an
important thing to keep in mind because
everybody wants a shortcut and the world
is all about hacks you know i'm gonna
i'm gonna hack into somebody's system
i'm gonna hack my metabolism i'm gonna
you know i'm gonna hack my sleep and all
that and almost anybody who's promising
you hacks is selling you a bill of goods
anything that's really going to do good
for you requires that you change your
life you're going to change your you
change the way that you live you know
you can't hack your weight because what
you're going to do is quickly lose
weight on some weird diet and gain all
the weight back and then some if you
really want to be healthier anyway you
know all that people kind of know about
that so that's the key thing to keep in
mind the four happiness habits as i
mentioned before are faith
family friendship and work that serves
other people and so those are the things
really to be spending time on now
to be sure people have different
metabolisms you know i talked about the
the the three macronutrients but there's
also metabolism so david you and i you
might just be a naturally happier person
than me because 50 of your baseline
happiness is genetic you know i don't
want it to be true but that's very
important information because that's why
your habits are that much more important
to sort of epigenetically help you to
express greater happiness
notwithstanding your genes a quarter of
your happiness is circumstantial but
because of homeostasis and the hedonic
treadmill the circumstances don't last
good and bad you know even if bad things
happen to you almost always that will
wear away pretty quickly and the good
things will too the quarter that really
matters is the four habits so the first
one is the faith thing and again that
your results may vary you've got to
figure out what that means to you if
you're not a traditionally religious
person then what we're talking about is
a transcendent view of life
everybody needs to understand their
values and live according to them people
need a contemplative practice people
need to um to to to surround themselves
with literature that's that's wise for
example so i recommend that people read
i don't care the stoic philosophers or
the holy books or or just something
smart 15 minutes a day that they engage
in a practice of of nature or prayer or
meditation and that they actually think
very clearly about their values so they
can get that first pillar that faith
pillar in order right family life is
unbelievably important i mean
i'm sure you join me in regretting the
fact that one in six americans is not
talking to a family member today because
of politics which is just
it's just like stepping over a hundred
dollar bills to get to nickels man right
it is insanity to do that i mean i know
aunt marge is the pain because she at
thanksgiving she can't stop talking
about trump but but man if you call aunt
marge at 2am with a crisis she's picking
up the phone and all your buddies on on
you know whatever the democracy
underground they're like who are you
that's important that we keep that in
mind and then when we talk about uh
about friendships
i mean people can't see us right now but
i'm wearing a t-shirt that says real
friends beat deal friends
and you know for the strivers out there
the super drivers it's all deal no real
we got to get that in order and finally
your work i mean we all work and
most americans like their jobs well
enough
the key thing to loving your job and
having it bring joy to you is not i mean
it's got to pay well enough obviously
you got to pay your rent but it's all
about earning your success and serving
other people and you know that's where
really comes in and so it's love of the
divine whatever that means to you love
your family love your friends and loving
others through your work love love love
and more love you know if people didn't
know your your backstory
i think the way you talk about these
issues
people would be surprised that you were
sort of like professional right winger
for a while running the american
enterprise institute and you know people
check out our conversation 15 years ago
or however however long ago it was they
might be surprised to hear you talk this
way is that
wrong or do you find that what you're
doing now does appeal more to people on
the political left than the right
it appeals to everybody because
everybody wants to be happy you know i
have a completely non-partisan audience
i mean i write for the atlantic and you
know my personal i mean look everybody's
got their political views and one of the
biggest problems that we have for
happiness is america in america is we
we're too
identified our identities are too
political i mean david you and i have
you know 95 in common and the five
percent that's not is a bunch of
political views that would be relatively
trivialized if you were pulling me out
of a burning car absolutely you know
it's super important that we not get too
hung up on these types of things and
furthermore that we can love and respect
each other
not despite our political differences
but because of our political differences
as far as i'm concerned the most
interesting people are the ones who
disagree with me not the ones who agree
with me on every matter i mean none of
my kids vote like me
i don't care i mean it's like
all three of my kids voted for trump you
know and so it's is that true oh yeah
it's not my thing but it's it's it's you
know let's bring it on give me your
reasons you know i want to hear it is
the whole thing
more is the bottom line i think that
makes sense to a lot of people i think
where it becomes more difficult is when
the differences are
directly hostile to who we feel we are
right so differences between me and a
white nationalist for example
okay i mean it started we start to get i
think into that maybe it's less common
fortunately but those differences are
harder to overcome
they're harder to overcome but we're
having a tendency today because we're
being manipulated by people who are
making a big buck on our hatred
and us thinking that the differences of
ideology are actually in differences of
the of existence and that's a big
problem that we have you know somebody
who disagrees with the way that i live
my life is not denying my right to exist
those are two very different things and
the problem is we become
too disengaged from our common story and
too i think involved in our differing
identities identities are like i'm this
and you're not so you're not in my in
group you're in my out group and you
know you and i as i said before have a
90 something percent overlapping common
story that is the basis of our
brotherhood sure i mean you and i are
just i mean it's super important that we
see each other as as
you know with the equal dignity
radically and then if you disagree with
me really strongly about something
that's not my denying your right to
exist and and yet a lot of scholars a
lot of politicians
are trying to effectively a lot of let
me put not to find a point on it a lot
of people my age a lot of baby boomers
are trying to conscript a lot of child
soldiers into their culture war
by convincing a lot of young people to
be really hateful and afraid
of people who say one particular thing
or who have particular moral views as if
they wanted you dead which isn't true on
the right or the left
yeah i i generally tend to agree with
that i think that where we get into a
riskier space is
when we minimize that there's lots of
people out there who maybe they don't
want to deny your right to exist like
maybe they're not talking about killing
those with whom they disagree but they
want to deny them basic rights and then
there's a question as to where do you
draw the line as to when are these just
casual differences which we can easily
overcome
yeah no for sure and you know if
somebody wants to deny your basic rights
i mean you can see that on both sides
constantly when i saw our our senator
elizabeth warren talking about crisis
pregnancy centers last week saying we
need to shut them all down you know and
you could take that and say oh therefore
under the circumstance there's nothing
for us to talk about we need to break
away as a nation there's no way that we
can live together or we can say you know
people say these things they talk in
this particular way elizabeth warren
actually is a good senator who wants to
represent me she does a lot of things
that are right and not taking the most
radical thing that somebody says and
interpreting it in the most radical way
possible we got to be more charitable to
each other as the bottom line i think
that is hard for me to disagree with
that's for sure
we've been speaking with arthur brooks
his latest book is from strength to
strength finding success happiness and
deep purpose in the second half of life
arthur great speaking to you again i
really appreciate it
you too neighbor um you know we're both
massachusetts natives although i know
our audience is far and wide you're
you're reaching even outside american
borders these days aren't you these days
yes uh and there are many people in
scotland resisting it i will tell you
we're not no i'm kidding yeah we are we
are and mostly u.s uh i'm sorry uh
english-speaking countries but big in
germany i will tell you
that's great to hear i'm glad to hear it
congratulations on your success you
deserve it